[Music]
hey Dad hi sweetheart
why are you steady group gonna go eight
oh one more thing I wanna don't let the
final you took today i'm marga and 15
student 9-1-1 what's your emergency
I'm calling to report a missing person
okay who is this regarding my daughter
I'm the detective assigned to your
daughter's case I need to know how
everything unfolded understood I think
we're gonna go lately my one after study
session Margot didn't return home
Margo Kim school has her marked as
absent today - she didn't attend school
on Friday
my daughter is in a lesson with you
right now
Margo Castle turned classes six months
ago and three
she's been transferring funds for the
last six months we'll handle the ground
investigation but as a parent you can
help us with who your daughter talks to
is that something you can do
yes do you mind answering some questions
for me to help here eat lunch alone on
Thursday and Friday
don't think she's involved with anything
serious I know my daughter that close
she has friends right I knows why did
you invite her to study boots reading in
the Berkley next year when was the last
time you saw her she did not run away
Lucan team has been missing since last
Thursday made a transaction of $2,500
I know my daughter where were you
I didn't know her didn't know my
daughter
[Music]
you